what if
what if aliens Were Real uh it doesn't
have to be aliens could be yeah could be
us
yeah I know if if there was something
there in terms of advanced technology
that would be very very why do you say
technology
uh because you know if it's not
technology it's going to be magic and I
think technology is kind of the things
to come through first oh you're talking
about the uh you know perhaps like some
kind of weird government cover-up type
thing no no no no no slowed down
okay
I'm mostly interested in this ultimately
because of science
not technology
I don't think
that I know anything about their there's
no reason that this has to involve new
science
but if I saw somebody
explode an atomic weapon
before the neutron was discovered I'd
search for the neutron
sure
so right the neutron I covered in 1932
which I keep thinking about my aunt is
older than the discovery of the neutron
what's interesting here is assume for
the moment that that slim possibility
that you and I both acknowledge exists
that we could be looking at alien
technology but it would be built on
science we don't have yes not technology
because people keep freezing Einstein in
which has become very distressing to me
you cannot go faster than the speed of
light within Einstein's construct
but Einstein's construct is the map not
the territory we don't know whether a
better map allows us to do things that
are prohibited on this map but not
necessarily with a better understanding
of reality so if this were Technology
based on new science held by some
civilization that we don't know anything
about could be us from the future could
be somebody from
neighboring galaxies who knows what it's
hugely consequential scientifically and
one of the things that causes me to
despite wanting to get on with you and
understand each other better you know
also sort of push back relatively
forcefully
is I don't want that window stigmatized
anymore it's like it's enough
sure uh well I think with the technology
versus Science question I'm kind of in
the why not both Camp uh new science is
great and new technology would indicate
new science but new technology is also
an implementation of that understanding
of those scientific principles which in
itself would be useful and interesting
they should be clear about why I'm
saying it as well
there is a general tilt away from
science towards technology and they're
too hijacked conversations one is that
every time we end up talking about this
it goes to the technology discussion
because markets have been hot and
Science in particular physics has been
kind of stagnant for a long time
and that means that people
inadvertently start thinking about new
technology from old science if we don't
actually keep talking about science the
other thing is that Elon has more or
less taken a an imperative which is that
humans figure out whether we can stop
sharing one planet in one atmosphere in
order to diversify our risk and turned
it into a conversation about SpaceX and
Mars
and in both cases what we're doing is
we're we're taking away from a very real
conversation which is we've got a
potential you know situation with the
dictator who's invaded a neighboring
country as if the 20th 20th century
never happened in Europe of all places
right next to Article 5 territory this
is extremely dangerous and if human
beings don't take the message from covid
and from Putin in Ukraine that we better
try to figure out whether we can spread
out because anything like an Airborne uh
respiratory virus or you know radiation
can cover the planet very quickly
um we're in trouble so it's very
important to me to prop the window open
to is it possible to leave this place
and the the chief reason that we are
unlikely to be able to leave this place
and thus we are likely to die in
relatively short order due to our
technological prowess and our lack of
wisdom
is the einsteinian limit on travel
now
it's very hard to prop that window open
because people have Frozen Einstein in
and Elon in and those two individuals
have changed this conversation the
einsteinian contribution means we always
talk about is faster than light possible
which we shouldn't be talking about
we talk about wormholes we talk about
alcubieri drives we talk about time
dilation and multigen we talk about
uploading into silicon all of these
things are useless
right
on the other front Elon has focused Us
in in the diversity conversation
to diversify from all on Earth to all on
Earth plus Mars as if we're going to
terraform Mars before Elon turns 60.
and both of these are very dangerous
conversations when we have a very narrow
hope of asking should we be looking
to figure out whether there's something
Beyond Einstein which gives us
possibilities Beyond Einstein so this is
one of the reasons I'm most interested
in the Overton window here which is
if Einstein's restrictions persist
in the alt to the ultimate Theory
we're in a lot of trouble it means we're
probably not going anywhere and we our
only hope is to stabilize this planet
which I don't see much hope in doing
given how powerful we've become
um and we have to get away from
technology and from rockets and from
Elon and from Einstein if we're going to
actually turn this into a legitimate
question which is is there anywhere we
can actually go or as is likely the case
we're stuck here
and I think again why not in the why not
both camps uh it's uh you know obviously
we need to develop our technology and
yes it would be great if we had more
adventurous explorations of physics but
I don't really see how what I'm doing in
any way uh Narrows the Overton or
expands I want people I want people who
think they have UFO data
to be welcomed scientifically
and not stigmatized and made to feel as
if they're absolutely freaks of course
for me if people have UFO data yeah I
think yeah I personally I'm very happy
to look at that data I'm not just going
to dismiss it out of hand I'm going to
analyze it uh now I guess the question
you're raising there is should other
scientists be looking at this with some
degree of seriousness and yeah there's
there's an issue there there is this
stigma in science uh but I think that
stigma is is largely well founded
because of all the ridiculous stuff that
comes along with with UFOs and I think
if there was some good evidence then
people like the UAP task force would
have actually brought it forward and
actually done something with it where
where are our top physicists
uh I don't know you're a top business
well you're a physicist I don't know
where you are in the the world rankings
but uh
I'm actually a mathematician but I don't
know anybody in the top physics
Community who knows what the hell's
going on here yeah well nobody knows
what's going on
so it's not like you know they've been
given the evidence and they've studied
it and they've determined that there's
nothing is going on it's that the
evidence
the evidence isn't really very good
well is the fact that our top people
don't have the evidence
indicative of something
um I I don't I don't know I I think
from my perspective I think it's more
likely that the evidence doesn't
rise to the level where it would you
would be able to justify bringing in
outside people now if it's something you
know like the the Manhattan Project
where they've brought in a whole bunch
of scientists you know there's a lot of
motivation there there was a lot of
reason to believe that you know the race
for the atomic bomb was a very important
matter of of national survival but with
with UFOs you know the base level of
evidence doesn't really seem to be there
we don't have this this huge push that
would be justified if there was actually
this evidence of new technology or new
physics out there which would be worth
trillions of dollars uh instead we get
these stupid little programs with with
22 million dollars well it doesn't make
any sense it seems like they might even
not really be they almost might be
decoys for relatively small amounts of
money are you familiar with the history
that brought in
the great topologist Solomon left shits
and Bryce DeWitt
uh
and Peter Higgs and Louis Whitton
together where there were two very weird
efforts one nakedly anti-gravity
um by a guy named Babson
uh
uh no I'm not really familiar with that
but I've heard you talked about it
before they uh the kind of this secret
Gravity Research yeah
so there was there was there was a very
weird thing whereby in the 1950s
there was like if you look at feynman's
uh popular books he talks uh there's a
story called any questions where he gets
a black eye and a bar that was
frequented by bookies and prostitutes
yeah what he's actually talking about is
that he was going to Buffalo from
Cornell
to an aerospace company to deliver
lectures
and there was this weird Confluence
between Aerospace it's what's known as
the general the Golden Age of general
relativity and all of these top
scientists that's never made a wit of
sense
which almost certainly seems like there
was some sort of program
run through a couple of individuals
named Babson and bainson which is
extremely confusing
to bring a small Cadre of leading
scientists to discuss
something that sounds like anti-gravity
in the guise of discussing general
relativity anew
right
and I would dearly like to know
what that program actually was yeah and
I would like more of us to be talking
openly because we know for example that
Solomon left shets was was affiliated
with this crazy Gravity Research
Foundation
is there a bunch of like classified
documents about that that people have
been trying to get or is there just
nothing there because it seems to me
like David Kaiser at MIT the physicist
and historian would probably be the best
person to answer that I've never gotten
at this nor have I put in the time or
the energy I've just noted that for some
reason suddenly in the 1950s general
relativity which had been asleep since
the late teens wakes up as a field
there's a conference at the University
of North Carolina Chapel Hill which
Feynman attends which all of this seems
to be spurred by two individuals
um one of which creates the What's
called the research institute for
advanced study to make it sound like the
institute for advanced study the other
is something called like something we
Institute for the study of physical
fields at UNC North Carolina uh Chapel
Hill
and there's some weird thing between the
Martin
Aircraft Company Wright-Patterson Air
Force Base a bunch of these sorts of
things and I never even heard anyone
talk about them to put it all together
until I talked to Kaiser and I said am I
losing my mind
he's like no no this is this really
weird history where
the great I mean just to put a weird
period on it the the top mind in
theoretical physics is the son of the
leading anti-gravity researcher from the
1950s it's a very bizarre State of
Affairs
I guess you gotta try to think what what
might have actually happened and from my
perspective it kind of the most likely
hypothesis I'm just closing this out
there is that there was a a research
program into something that was quite
extraordinary
uh but it didn't pan out in the same way
that uh project Stargate was a research
program into remote viewing you know
this is obviously a bit more hard
science but it was something they
thought oh the Russians are going to be
looking into this type of thing we too
should form a working group maybe do
working groups and try to figure out if
we can figure out what they figured out
and they look into it but you know the
same way that Stargate nothing happened
nothing happens there but it's
classified stays classified and it's a
mystery I mean no technology that we
know of is anti-gravity nothing
apparently came from it unless there's
this weird parallel track of science
that is going on
anti-gravity may be a head fake which
means that it's really just post
space-time physics
it's now become very fashionable in
theoretical physics to say that
space-time is the problem and that it's
doomed as a concept and that what we're
looking for is the successor to
Einstein's sort of fabric for reality
um it may be that anti-gravity is a
really bad name for something to make it
sound junky
but what we're really talking about in
particularly the presence of left sheds
is very interesting here
um
that what we may be discussing is a
post-romanian or pseudo-ramanian
understanding of of space-time just a
geometric replacement
yeah and I had you talk on Brian Keating
show about how you thought that might be
um kind of related to UFOs in a way and
that's uh whatever the UFOs are kind of
represents a someone who has access to
that higher level understanding that's
above
yeah or it could be that it's all
nonsense and it's all disinformation I
mean look I'm very open-minded about
this uh I was in a discussion with Sam
Harris not too long ago and he said that
one of the characteristics that he had
noticed that differentiate us is that he
tends to be very closed on the way in
relative to my openness on the way in
but that he notes that I don't tend to
slide all the way down the slippery
slope to say yeah it's definitely aliens
and what I'm trying to do is really to
keep that possibility open that what
we're talking about is we're talking
about a science program not a technology
program not a defense program
that has techno technological and
Military and security implications
see yeah I I I'm all for keeping
everything on the table and this is part
of my my general philosophy of
Investigation I'm glad to hear that is
that I would uh I would keep like you
know some kind of advanced technology or
new physics or
um or aliens or even things like
um
yeah say the simulation hypothesis you
know perhaps these things are a glitch
in The Matrix that's it's a possibility
uh it does seem like there's any good
evidence for it but it's something that
you why not consider that why not have
all these things in the mix because if
you're closing off various things you
might close off things by accident okay
so look there are minor branches of the
decision tree that I find so remote is
to say that you know
I really don't want to spend time on it
but what what I'm asking time on it what
you keep it around
well I guess what I'm asking is
do you see any banal branches of this
decision tree
that are still alive I mean yeah well
yeah I I think that there's a very big
branch of the decision tree that does
not involve
um you know extraordinary flying craft I
think there's a a large possibility
there's a large possibility as a all the
UFO encounters have essentially
um you know simple explanations uh and
in those simple explanations I would
include things like experimental
aircraft by the US government and
perhaps occasionally experimental
aircraft uh by other governments but the
vast majority are going to be things
like uh like Airborne clutter people
misidentifying things uh people having
hallucinations from stress like fighter
pilots who have been in the air for a
real long time uh things like that and I
think that's that's is
definitely the Avenue of this decision
tree of what things might be that that I
go down and I think it's likely to be a
decision tree that has very many leaves
it's probably not the right the right
way of putting it because it still think
it's still like you end up at one leaf
but you don't there's all these
different things you're going to end up
with a branch that has lots of Blues and
all of these things are contributing to
what we actually see people people see
things that are optical illusions like
this triangle thing like a dc-8 looks
exactly like a triangle because it has a
light on each wingtip and a red one in
the middle and it looks like a triangle
with three lights on the corners and a
red thing in the middle so that probably
accounts for a bunch of those there's
lots and lots of different things and
other then there's also this other layer
of it which is this this government
um you know the pressure from the
invisible College these people who are
really into it and the government people
in government who are either
you know some more corrupt they're
getting Kickbacks or whatever and if
people pay them to do things or they
just have interest themselves there's
all these complicated layers of things
going on that doesn't really involve
some vast new hidden parallel track of
science or defense departments like
science program or or aliens or Time
Travelers or anything like that so I
would keep those things as possibilities
but it seemed like to me everything is
probably going to be in this this big
Old Branch over here you just watched a
clip from the theories of everything
channel for the full video and all its
magnificence then click here and if
you'd like to see more then subscribe
enjoy